it's the last day we got you through
high school I need to go if and with
your budget numbers man we just graduate
head off to college that should do it I
can't hear you
I can't soundproof class you have to go
to a party to me what nobody knows that
we are fun they didn't party because we
wanted to focus on school and get into
good colleges and it worked
irresponsible people who partied also
got into those colleges how did you try
to actively subvert the kind of teenage
movie tropes that we've seen time and
time again well we just decided we were
gonna smash the patriarchy with the idea
of making the funniest characters in the
movie the women and most of the
characters in the movie frankly are
women but we really wanted to take the
idea of the kind of convenience
stereotypes that exist in most of these
movies of like the smart girls and the
[ __ ] girls and the Mean Girls and just
say what if everybody is all of these
things what if we really celebrate
multidimensionality and what if we take
the idea of oh they're not in most of
these films it's like assimilation is
the goal you're like what if that wasn't
the goal what if the goal starts with
just proving something a sort of noble
cause that then reveals itself to be
about actually a lot more self-discovery
than they realized they were even
looking for so we just tried to go
deeper with you know while celebrating
what makes those movies so fun all the
teen movies we've all loved our whole
lives you know everything from clueless
to Dazed and Confused and everything in
between we wanted to celebrate that art
form which is so fun and kind of endemic
and you know generation-defining but
make it a little bit more nuanced and I
think it's it's fun too because
audiences bring so much of what they
think they know about those movies to a
story that it's easy if you point out
someone and they seem like the hot girl
or they seem like the smart girl or they
seem like the mean girl
how much we project onto that ourselves
and so being able to dismantle that
throughout the story the audience as
well as kind of the main characters was
a really fun opportunity and I love that
it celebrates female friendship but
something we need to see more of on
screen yeah we did see that in Lady Bird
Feeny but you tell us about the truths
that this film tells about female
friends
I think that the dynamic between Molly
and Amy which of our characters is it's
just so special
these girls it's like they have this
connection that has truly taken them
through their entire lives like without
each other it's all I know I love like
the little details of it to like my
character often stays over it Kaitlyn's
characters house and she has her own
drawer and it says like Molly's surely
not was the same like my friends would
leave you know their pajamas at my house
and like the little details when they're
all added up that's that specificity
makes it so universal in some way so I
think the way that we captured or this
female friendship I think is so
important because those those
connections that you make with people
especially between two women at that age
are so formative and so kind of like
feed your soul and feed your heart and I
think if there's anything that our film
celebrates the most it's just love your
friends hard and keep them really close
and I think that's we go on such of an
adventure and we meet the most
incredible people specifically an iconic
performance every year it teaches you to
like really value your friends and
Billy's character hurt like every
character has a group of friends within
it that gets celebrated like I like my
characters seems like this insane like
party girl that's really full of herself
and it's just her world but when you
really get to know her she is so
insanely loyal to her best friend that
she would literally kill for him and you
don't really know that until you know
her well I stripped down this facade
that she's created yeah and she seems
like she's someone who's unashamedly
herself
big-time very hard to do when you're a
young girl especially you told all these
certain things exactly I wish I would
have been more like Gigi I mean in some
ways I loved watching just you two
walking in the door before singing the
songs together it seems like you have a
real friendship was that easy to create
oh it was instant I fell in love with
being the second I laid eyes
what you do have is special we are going
to show each other how much we care
about each other
please do a Korean face mask I don't
need to know all the words I know but we
lived together during the movie and it
was the greatest time filled with snacks
and pancakes and sleeping until 2 p.m.
because we would get home at 6 a.m.
because we would start our days at 6
p.m. because we had night shoots most
timezone together oh no I was our own
world are you appetite yet she just like
get into my bed I do eat pancakes and we
would run lines and it was just like it
was heaven I'm loosing a lot of peace in
the scripts I remember one time I
overslept and I was still asleep
and you thought we call each other pup
well Olivia you look like a proud mom
what was it like to be on set and and
feel this real friendship film I mean it
was extraordinary because that takes a
lot of commitment that takes a lot of
you know devotion to the project that
when they say you know the rest of the
world nothing else mattered I mean it's
true when you really commit to a project
as an actor it's all-consuming and
that's not easy to do and it takes a
real love for the material so for me I
just felt overwhelming gratitude that
everyone felt the material was worthy of
that kind of commitment and that went
you know behind the camera as well we
were asking a lot of everyone to make
this film and there was this shared
sense of purpose which I think just made
us feel everyday just so delighted and
truly I was just grateful at every
single moment I couldn't believe it was
a real set with real snacks you know it
was it was exciting directing music
videos is a really interesting way into
directing features and I recommend it
but I one thing that's kind of
fascinating is musicians have to commit
a hundred percent in order to perform a
musician can't go out on stage and
perform a song at 40 percent it just
doesn't work
and when you direct a musician in a
music video and you sense this real
hundred percent commitment it's really
thrilling and I thought God how is that
going to be when directing actors in a
long forming I'd done a short but in a
feature can you ask someone to give you
that full commitment for this for six
weeks and I just was amazed at how
everyone kind of willingly and
graciously gave me that and I just was
so inspired I thought gosh you know if I
ever act again I really hope these
hard-working as these people but I I
really yeah I was just overwhelmed with
gratitude the whole time
well can you guys embarrass the live
here and tell me how great she was no
they're doing it tonight
and I was like Caitlin didn't catch a
word she's too beautiful I didn't catch
one single word perfect everything that
came out of her mouth was genius and I'm
just gonna leave he was saying like it
all comes from live it's like this this
energy this vibe of confidence and worth
warmth and intellect just radiates off
of her and she just it was really
inspiring to watch her with the crew too
because they just like loved her and
like loved the vibe that she sat in the
entire ensemble cast is so brilliant and
everyone came in and just like slayed it
and it was all because you believed in
them so hard and I think it sounds like
that goes against the misnomer that to
be a director you have to be like this
tough army general yeah there's no truth
in that I think people do that out of
insecurity and they think in order to
make people respect me I have to sort of
diminish their value I don't know how
that mat works yeah I was so scared of
you I had to prove I was better than you
you know that sort of idea I think is
what's bringing directors onto a set and
giving them some sort of shield against
the
the enormity of the undertaking and yet
what they're missing is that if you open
yourself up and really lay yourself bare
to your crew to your actors and say this
is the story I want to tell I need your
help we're doing this together they will
lift you up and help you tell the best
story possible but if you kind of if you
feel the need to to diminish them they
won't you're shutting off the valve that
allows for the storytelling I don't even
understand it but I I guess I do because
I've been on sets with terrible
directors and I know I can sense that
it's all coming from from a place of
fear yeah yeah
you